that really generic home invasion movie
from last year gets a sequel the purge
anarchie so the purge anarchies a sequel
to the PIRs you remember the purge where
it was like murders legal for one day
and you're like that's really
interesting in the movie was just some
generic home invasion murder movie where
you're like I've seen this a zillion
times before and this one who
concentrates more on the purge and
that's actually really cool
it's how the trailer for this movie I
was like holy it's like they're
listening to their fans and I got to
give this movie props for that it's
always awesome when filmmakers hear the
fans and they're like yeah well okay
well we'll take that into account in my
review of the purge when I said it was
just a generic home invasion movie
whether or not murder is legal or
illegal doesn't matter because they're
breaking into a house and trying to kill
a family and the families fighting them
off and that happens whether or not
murder is legal or illegal I saw a
comment in the comments section where
someone was like yeah it would have been
a lot better some of us say a couple or
a family their car broke down in the
middle of the Persian now they have to
survive the purge and I was like yes
that would feel like you're actually in
the world where murder is legal and lo
and behold when I saw the trailer I was
like that's exactly what they did I had
to have taken that from fans and that's
one of the story arcs in this movie was
not the only one ultimately in this
movie got the badass from Captain
America the Winter Soldier who's kind of
a dick also buddy's a badass and pretty
much everything he's in I'd like to do
if you ever want like a gruff likeable
badass hard guy in a movie didn't put
him in it he's a man on a mission on
purge night you can tell he's not
completely a dick because he sees his
family getting taken and he's like
alright I'll help so he helps them and
ultimately this group of five people get
together him included and now they have
to get from point A to point being
survived the purge this will be just
ridiculous in every sense of the word it
kind of reminded me of twisted metal you
know you got the souped-up cars you got
a semi in the back rolls up this dude
has a Gatling gun in an apron and he
just slices just killing people just
shooting him I was like that is
something out of twisted metal it was
like twisted metals going on but then
these five people they don't have a car
they just run and you can tell the purge
anarchy wants to set up for the next
movie to be bigger you know maybe they
want like an anthemic is trilogy or
maybe they'll be like saw and they'll
just keep it going every year I don't
know probably that I say saw because
this is what it kind of reminded me
but it reminded me of an enjoyable Saw
movie you're not going to be like that
is great filmmaking it's a great movie
x-men Days of Future past
Apes who gives a about those those
purge movies man that's where it's at
not gonna happen it's a simple ass
premise for sure but you know what
you're getting into when you go into
this movie people are going to die
people are going to try to kill people
are going to kill and people are going
to be running but again at least it
feels like it is within a movie where
murder is legal tonight tonight is an
exception to all rules of life I feel
like the purge Anarchy might as well be
called the purge Mulligan it's a radio
it's a ray throw it's what people were
looking for in the first movie that they
actually hit more in this movie movie
simple but it tries to be bigger when it
tries to be more epic than it probably
should be feel like it's overreaching
like dude don't do that you feel like
the next one's gonna be this hardcore
revolution against the government you're
like what are you Mockingjay you're not
that man you're like the 2 to 10 million
dollar movie that makes 30 million
dollars and you're all good being that
the crew of five people that one of them
is interesting the rash you're like
whatever it dude I'm not gonna lose
sleep that's another thing about this
movie I never felt like the attention
was holy one of them might die for
the most part they're all right because
I got Solid Snake behind I mean the
support cast would have been perfectly
functional if they were cannon fodder to
die in a movie like this which is
usually what a support cast in a movie
like this is but none of them really
dies you're like what's the point of you
I'm supposed to care I don't care in the
end the purge Anarchy succeeds in the
simple premise that is trying to go for
which is people need to survive this
night that's a special night because
murder is legal on this night but it
also fails and it's overreaching to try
to be this revolutionary franchise epic
I mean revolutionary in the sense of a
revolution they're trying to overthrow
the government mainly it's a badass
he carries roles like this really well
this is no exception it's completely
unbelievable but know what you're going
into in this movie and you'll probably
have fun with it as laughable as this
movie is since I enjoyed myself I will
say the purge anarchy it's a pretty good
time to alcohol required so the purge
Anarchy have you seen it what did you
think about it but every fat comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more